we're so fat and lazy in america our  gyms have to have slogans now to  motivate us  right it used to be hey come get the  silver gold platinum right now it's you  know this cute [ __ ] planet fitness is  what is it judgment free zone  hey you fat fox get in here now it's  fine now bring the sandwich bring the  sandwich you got mayo on your lip  doesn't matter we'll tint the windows  you [ __ ] monster get in here  [Applause]  judgment free  that's a nice gesture but then it got me  thinking where are all these other gyms  that are apparently bullying and mocking  people  because i've yet to go to a gym and just  have someone be like  oh my god  look at this [ __ ] moose look at this  20 bucks this kid's got the bad diabetes  which is the bad one  which is the bad one one or two tim  this kid's gonna lose a foot in two  weeks let's  let's go around and judge him for a  while